hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner we've got
some interesting news to talk about
today foreigner and doing some nice
special events which some of you may or
may not have seen if you went on their
Twitter or the Ubisoft Twitter what
we'll talk about that towards the end of
the video but as always like to be if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational site a foreigner
that bean balance changes hero updates
Patchett's and leaks better be kept up
to date with everything happening and
within the world of foreigner and never
miss on an update then we stay subscribe
the channel
my Twitter and discord will be in the
description down below and with that
let's get started first up is the usual
sales of items this being some
executions that you can get as well as
an event challenge and in arcade quest a
very simple stuff on top of that hyper
duel is finally released now today and
we can now play it and they show a
little bit of sneak peek gameplay of
what you're gonna be expecting when you
hop into the game so as you're seeing on
screen this is some hyper duel between
the developers and it's basically one
round of duel with multiple wives every
time you die you lose a life the person
who dies it will get invincibility upon
spawning and a speed boost as to not be
spawn camp and the very smaller we're
gonna that you're in and then it goes
back to a regular duel so it's very up
in your face action with multiple lives
and it actually seems a lot of fun I
can't wait to play it and see if it's
actually as intense as it sounds so then
we let me know in the comments below if
you guys are enjoying this mode if you
fledge already also arcade it had a
state of balance today and i know not
many of you play arcade or some of you
do but i will still let you know anyway
but yes arcade to get a little bit of a
state of balance and I will go be going
over that recap
so first up 50% of all quests played
with in arcade are the weekly cost which
is what they're hoping for you get a lot
of unique rewards in there and it's a
lot of fun because they can kind of
spice up the story within the arcade so
they're really happy that a lot of
people are enjoying the weekly quest and
also there is a 90% success rate which
is absolutely incredible for the weekly
quest which is nice because they want to
make the arcade a lot more fun and
enjoyable but not a chore but they are
going to be dumbing that down a little
bit because 90% was a little bit much
than we're asking for so they might make
it just a tad bit harder to get a
specific number 80 percent 70 percent
something around there because that
seems like it's way too easy for us to
go through it and
the recent quests that I remember
playing it is definitely super easy to
play but for the future they want to
make sure that more unique quests are
added monitored the new difficulty which
is like I said changing that 90% to
maybe an 80 or a 70 and then adding
while also improving on the modifiers
and the maps that you play in as well
and then lastly we have to talk about
the special event that foreigner will be
attending and it's exactly like last
year we are going back to e3 now you may
have already heard a couple other
youtubers talk about this but either way
regardless if this is your first time or
your tenth time hearing it it is still
good things to know and it's really
happy news if you guys are unaware last
time we went to e3 that was when we
showcased or four on our showcase the
marching fire the huge season 8 patch
with all the woven heroes in the breach
mode and everything we've come to know
now that was all showcased at e3 and
that was an incredible trailer and
easily one of my favorite trailers and
intro cutscenes and everything for the
entire game and nothing can beat that
now with III obviously it's not going to
be us we're gonna be getting Ghost Recon
break point the division - I believe
Rainbow six siege is making an
appearance steep is in therefore III and
the Ubisoft conference but we're going
to be part of this as well
as for what it is I have about three
options of what I think it might be
possibly for the first option is going
to be season 11 showcase now currently
we're in season 10 we're not even
halfway through with it yet even though
it seems like we've been doing this for
months
currently like I said we're I think in
campaign two so we haven't even seen
anything in regarding season 11 which is
supposed to be the new fighting hero so
my thoughts is that it could also be
talking about that on top of that it
could also be one of other two things
the other one being year for content
which as you may know I think is most
likely going to happen or an entirely
new sequel of four on or two the reason
I want to choose your four is not only
because then that will make me a hell of
a lot more less stress thinking that we
might not have a year for I still think
we will but I'm still kind of stressing
about that every time I think about it
and it was also the way that they did
III last time C for honor I believe was
in season six we were still getting
reworks at the time and we had no idea
what this was so they showed off
completely new content
and we had no idea that season 8 was
gonna be a thing I mean of course I
believe of course we speculated about it
but we had no clue what was gonna be
involved in that and then all of a
sudden boom four heroes new maps new
game-mode everything just all releasing
in one time and it was incredible as for
the content that we know right now we
are aware that there will be a season
eleven biking hero and a season twelve
Wulin hero so I'm assuming since we
already know that they're gonna keep
giving us info in the in the future of
what we don't know which could be year
for content if they don't do that and
they give us a seagull that's literally
better than any of the other options
that I chose that I just suggested
because a sequel for this game would be
amazing and I would love to play that
but if it is the season 11 gameplay for
the new hero or anything like that I'm
totally cool with that - I'd love to
know the new Viking hero as a lot of
people are talking about now they're
more hyped about the Viking hero than
any of the other heroes and that's
completely fine we've known that the
Viking here will be a thing since the
year of the Harbinger teaser so I'm
super excited to see what it looks like
what the weapon is gonna look like it's
gonna be amazing
now this is the thing I wanted to talk
about because it kind of has me a little
bit interested see unyu softs website
they talked about the Ubisoft III
conference and when it's gonna start and
how it's gonna play out so it's going to
be at June 10th at 1:00 p.m. and it
basically says this this is the year not
to be missed it is bigger than ever and
will include updates on steep for honor
trials and Assassin's Creed Odyssey as
well some special prizes then at 1:00
p.m. this will be for the main event
expect the unexpected as there will be
an unveiling of exciting new titles and
updates to your favorite games such as
Ghost Recon breakpoint the division 2
and for honor now this is going to lead
me to believe that there might be a for
honor sequel they didn't mention that
there was going to be new titles and
exciting updates in the second half that
I read and of that list Ghost Recon
breakpoint is the only one that has
actually new that was a huge game that
was teased roughly in the beginning of
May and we have no clue that's above but
that's not really what we care about we
care about for honor and a lot of the
other games I mentioned those are just
currently games out right now who knows
the foreigners gonna be getting a sequel
and they're gonna be showing us some
year for content
I'd love to see it but that's just my
opinion let me know yours down below and
yeah guys that's gonna be the end of the
visit hopefully you guys did enjoy a
little bit of a short room but I really
wanted to have a somewhat decently long
discussion about e3 because that was the
huge hype of marching fire and I of
course wanted to keep that hype for this
new year because going to e3 means a lot
cuz that can mean a huge amount for the
game in general getting a lot of players
to play it and then just having a lot of
just interesting info to think about and
speculate about so I'd love to see it
I'm really hoping it's gear 4 or even
better a sequel if it is season 11
that's okay but I feel like that could
have waited for a dev stream but that's
just my opinion what that guys like to
view if you do enjoy subscribe for new I
cover the informational slide a
foreigner that being balanced changes
here updates patch woods and leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never missed an update
especially the III cap because that
[ __ ] is gonna be long as [ __ ] and I
will still be watching it to make sure
all of you guys know what's happening
with that so definitely stay tuned to
the channel the Twitter and discord will
be in the description down below and my
two most recent videos are gonna be
popping up on screen during the outro
you guys want to watch those I highly
recommend it and with that take care
guys enjoy the rest of your day let me
know what's what you think is gonna be
happening at e3 for for honor and what
the future of the game is gonna entail
and with that take care guys peace out
[Music]